the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
you
okay so today's
topic is gonna be biogas digesters
so our objectives for the class or this
session they're going to be to learn how
biogas digesters work when and where
they're appropriate some important
design considerations when you're
building biogas digesters and then we're
gonna build a small-scale one in lab so
you get to play with some of the stuff
so these are some pictures of biogas
digesters they've been around for a
couple hundred years or maybe 150 years
there are lots of different forms for
them as you can see their faces scale up
they can be anywhere from large
industrial ones like that one or they
can be smaller scale ones for just a
single farmer or single family and what
is a biogas digester is a question that
you may be asking so a biogas digester
is something that takes organic matter
normally animal human vegetable waste
and turns it into gas for cooking and
also turns it into fertilizer for crops
so it's basically taking organic matter
and putting it through a process and you
get gas and fertilizer from that the
process that breaks down the organic
matter is anaerobic digestion so you
have bacteria which are found in the
organic waste and when you put this when
you put them under anaerobic conditions
which means that they're not exposed to
oxygen they break down these they break
down all the organic wastes and form
methane gas and carbon dioxide and and
so you basically have a giant chamber I
guess and in this chamber you have your
your waste here with your bacteria and
it and you let it sit for a while it
takes about two weeks for them to start
working
once you get them going and they produce
they break down the material they break
down the organic matter in here and
produce gas and you normally have an
inlet and an outlet and what happens is
you put in more
janek matter through the inlet and it
pushed us out some of this slurry or
whatever is left over and so you got
fertilizer from this end and the entire
time you're producing gas which you can
extract from there so about biogas the
composition of biogas is mostly methane
and carbon dioxide so you have about
sixty percent methane about 40 percent
carbon dioxide and then their trace
amounts of nitrogen hydrogen hydrogen
sulphide and oxygen and yeah and the
amount of energy you can extract from
biogas is 20 mega joules per cubic meter
which is a fair bit yes I'm not exactly
sure right now I yeah I'll get back to
you on that
I had a chart with how it compares to
what like what how we can like things
but I didn't put it on here because yeah
and so so the parts of the biogas
digester are kind of like what I drew
here but better in this picture you have
a you have a trench where you put the
biogas digester you have to biogas
digester bag which is what contains all
of the manure and the slurry and the gas
then you have your Inlet and outlet and
you have a security valve and you have a
gas reservoir as well so we're gonna
talk a little bit now about why you
would have a biogas digester what are
the advantages and what are
disadvantages so now that you've learned
a little bit about it can we we can
brainstorm some ideas about why you
would use it or where you would use it
yeah
you you add water to it to make a slurry
so you mix manure and water and you got
this slurry and then you put it into the
system you guys will be doing that later
today too so I went to a farm and got
some fresh cow manure for you to work
with so yeah
if you want a ballpark size I guess
would be maybe like 10 or 15 feet does
that seem right 15 feet long maybe like
this size diameter like the trench would
be kind of like this corridor between
the two tables that's about the size
what you're looking at for yeah for like
a family a household one but they can
bake and range from like small to large
as well so if you look at this there's
there's actually a lot of design that
went into the specific biogas digester
and so we can look at the individual
components of it and figure out why I'm
trying to look through the design
process and thought process that they
used to come up with this design because
this is actually a pretty clever design
for a biogas digester so does anyone
notice anything about this diagram that
seems like a cool like a good idea for
them to have done
yeah the security valve is important you
don't want your thing blowing up yeah
reservoir is also good because with this
biggest storing gas is also somewhat of
a problem and if you don't have it
accessed like if you run up a place to
store the gas and access it pretty
easily then you're not gonna have yeah
do you guys think about the fence I
don't know if you guys can see it in
there but but there's a fence around the
specific design and a problem like one
of the things with this design is that
the bag the biogas digester bag for this
is it's a big plastic bag that's covered
in tarp that's sewn together and so you
have this sort of like giant plastic bag
that's sitting outside and one of the
cool things about it is it's really
cheap because you don't have to build an
external construction for it but it's
also like if you have cattle which is
which a lot of times you will have for
something like this and your cow steps
on this bag it's pretty much ruined
you're ruining your like $300 biogas
digester so so that's why they put a
fence there there can you not think of
other advantages to having a bag other
than just the fact that it's cheaper yes
it's not really transportable but you
can't you can't really move well maybe I
mean it might it's easier to transport
to the site you're installing to so you
can make one of these and I guess
transport them to the location I haven't
actually seen that done I've seen most
of them being installed on site from the
raw materials but it's definitely easier
to get a long large plastic bag than it
is to get all like the bricks you would
need to build a giant by the guest
register and seal it
yeah so that's actually a pretty cool
thing about this design is your your bag
can get bigger and smaller depending on
how much gas is being produced because
say you have if you have a rigid
structure kind of like okay so you have
I'm just gonna be draw when I just had
so you have a box right and it's say
it's made out of bricks you somehow
managed to steal it from the inside so
there's no air loss or gas loss which
isn't trivial for one but you managed to
do that and you put biogas in here and
it's filling up and it's producing
methane and or I guess it's producing
biogas what happens is you produce more
and more gas in this sort of design
you start you start getting a pressure
buildup of gas in here and if you're out
putting it into say the stoves here I've
got putting it into stove there
depending on what the pressure is if the
biogas in this chamber you're gonna get
a fluctuation in your stove temperature
or your flame front which is kind of
annoying and tricky to work with so if
you have if you have something that
expands like a bag it's better like
you'll have more of a constant pressure
there are some other designs that also
try to regulate the temperature not the
temperature the volume of the chamber
for the gas there's one called a
floating dumb one which is actually what
you'll be making and what it is is you
have a giant thing here you have you
have your container which is solid in
this case you have your your slurry here
and then you have a dome like this that
has your pipe coming out and what
happens is this can move up and down
inside of your chamber and so as you
produce more methane gas or biogas
rather as the pressure builds up it
pushes up on the dome so you're creating
more of a space and regulating pressure
with the size of the chamber which is a
pretty cool design and the ones you guys
are going to be making are kind of
similar to this but some of the thin
annotations are we gonna be you're gonna
take the bottom of a coke bottle it's
kind of like that and then you're gonna
fill it with water and you're gonna have
well you're gonna have you're gonna have
one by a guessing you're gonna have your
chamber with slurry and then you're
gonna have the valve coming into here
and coming out of the water and going up
into that chamber so this will be able
to
to move based on how much guests you
have in there
yeah you guys think of any other
advantages to having this sort of design
other than being able to regulate a
constant amount so how would I know how
much methane or biogas I'm gonna have in
this chamber with this design I like I
would have to put basically a pressure
valve on here and read pressure which is
kind of annoying and expensive and yeah
and it's not it's not really like easy
to get a pressure valve in a lot of
places but with a design like this if
you let it float the amount of you can
measure just the height of this chamber
because the higher the chamber the more
volume of biogas you have so it's almost
like an indicator that tells you how
much you have as well which is also
pretty cool but I've talked a lot about
how biogas digesters work in sort of the
design sense but we haven't really got
into why they're used or where they
would be applicable so so let's think
about some of some of when these work
what are the advantages of biogas to
other alternative cooking fuels we can
start by naming other sources of fuel
someone want to throw out other sources
of fuel that people use to Jeff charcoal
you have wood
anyone seen other techniques that they
use natural gas
I've seen in parts of other parts of the
world people actually just burn manure
straight
you also have electricity
yeah
in places they just take like cow dung
and just burn it there's a fuel source
just yeah they just take it and burn it
and then you cook your food over over it
so yeah you like you let it sit out in
the Sun it dries out it forms sort of a
briquette and you can just burn this
briquette and then it produces I mean it
really says energy when you burn it yeah
it gives off a lot of that smoke that
smell - and the other thing about
burning manure directly is that it's
kind of taking a product that's very
rich and like resources like there's a
lot of organic matter in there that
could be used as fertilizer and instead
of using the like these good properties
of that you're just combusting it and so
it's a waste of resources
basically to burn manure directly right
whatever what about wooden charcoal what
are disadvantages of that
yeah
okay it's definitely a big concern like
if you look at Haiti so much of Haiti is
deforested and in places where you don't
have access to like if you like in a lot
of parts of I guess India and Nepal
you'll have areas that are heavily
deforested already and so they don't
have access to wooden charcoal even and
charcoal is expensive there and in
places like that where people are
farmers or cattle farmers a technology
like biogas digesters makes sense any
other disadvantages to would maybe have
you ever tried what
just as a sense if any of you been to
developing world places where you've
seen people cook on three stone wood
fires or anything like that what did you
notice about the the cooking process do
you want to tell people about how they
cooked their
when they did click how did they was a
process that they used for cooking with
the fire or with the wood because their
various depending on where you are like
a lot of different ways of combusting
wood and using it mist of what abyss
stove look like
you like yeah
yeah and I mean like one of the biggest
problems with it is also just the smoke
that it releases and the fumes from that
which are both pretty bad like wood
fires cause a lot of pollution and most
people cook with wood fires inside their
houses and indoor air pollution is a
really big problem throughout the
developing world and so by I guess has
the advantage where it doesn't release
any of these toxic fumes yeah
I haven't seen have you seen that
concern I think the way a lot of people
like a lot of people I've seen you use
are you talking how are you talking
about I'm using the wood are you talking
about them like barbecuing something or
grillings
that's yeah I don't have much experience
with that so sorry can't help do you
okay what about natural gas what are
some of the problems associated with
natural gas yes
it's
I don't know I don't I don't think if it
is particularly dangerous it just you
need a lot of infrastructure to be able
to provide natural gas to people and
some places it's it's available and not
too bad like when I was working in a
favela in Brazil over this IEP they had
a truck come in with natural gas or LPG
and they would bring it every couple
days and at the same time and pick up
old containers and give people new
containers for certain price and that
seemed like it was great but you can't
really have that same sort of
infrastructure in a more rural place for
example when were we already talked
about and electricity is I mean in
places people don't really cook with
electricity that much in the developing
world like that I've seen so yeah by I
guess has a lot of advantages and in to
these other cooking methods but it also
neat it also requires certain things you
need like you basically need a lot of
manure or waste to go into this biogas
digester every day I think the minimum
recommendations are having maybe two
cows or something like that or a few
pigs and if you don't have if you don't
sort of meet these conditions you're not
going to be able to have a bio digester
that produces that much fuel for you to
cook off of and the investment for
building one isn't isn't paid back over
a reasonable period of time the the
other thing that's cool about by I guess
is that when you when you pass your if I
think if you're not using human waste if
you're using manure and you're using
agricultural waste if you or an organic
waste if you pass it through the biogas
digester at the end of it you get
fertilizer which is really good because
you're taking a waste product right now
which is animal waste and it smells bad
and people try to dispose of it as in
ways where they're not utilizing any
value from it and your
you're getting value from this product
which is like which is trash right now
which is a really cool idea plus when
you pass when you pass the waste through
the biogas digester a lot of the harmful
bacteria get killed off in the process
of producing or like one of it goes into
anaerobic conditions a lot of the
harmful bacteria get killed off so what
you're left with is good fertilizer that
you can use to grow your to grow crops
with and yeah so it's really just taking
a waste product and training and getting
value from there what are what are some
of the problems you can see with biogas
digesters based off of this cursory
introduction to them
yeah
yeah but I guess I just resusci bout or
I think the cheapest ones I've seen
around 300 dollars to build but they're
on the order of hundreds of dollars and
so that's pretty expensive to shell out
at once to build one of these another
big thing again we were you gonna say
something
yeah the maintenance costs are pretty
big as well and the problem with this is
there's so many parts as well that are
very critical to the functionality of it
that if one of them breaks you have to
fix it otherwise your entire thing
smells like if your bag gets a hole in
it all of your gas is gonna leak out so
you have to carefully design it and make
it so that and you have to really take
care of this because if you don't then
then it's just not gonna work anymore
there are a few things that in
particular logo or there are some common
sources of problems that you know that
by a guy's digesters have over time and
those are just leaks temperature and pH
so last year we did this lab in D lab
energy as well where we made by a guest
digesters and none of them produced any
methane gas or biogas and it was because
last year unlike this year D lab was
very very cold it was like you needed to
wear jackets around or you just wouldn't
be able to walk around here and by I
guess digesters need a warm temperature
I think around 50 degrees Celsius though
that seems high now no that seems high
I'll get back to you on the temperature
but you need a they have a pretty high
operational temperature and if they're
in that range then they work well and if
they're not in that range they don't
work well so if you're in an area that
gets cold a lot or it has like huge
temperature shifts then you're bacteria
that are producing methane under
anaerobic conditions are going to die
out because of the cold
and you have to you might have to come
up with some sort of heating device for
your body guys digester to keep it warm
the last thing is pH you want you really
need for these bacteria to survive you
need to have them at around a pH that's
like around 7 so I think 16 is
reasonable and if your pH drops below
that or gets raised above that then you
also have problems with biogas digester
is working so yeah I guess that's pretty
much all I had prepared for the bye guys
just like for the luxury part of this so
do you have any questions yes
no they're found I mean the bacteria
that are in the biogas digesters are the
same bacteria that are gonna be in your
stomach or cow's stomach sir and yeah so
they're just introduced or not
introduced they're just found in them
anywhere so it needs to be separated at
least because there's sort of like the
liquid part and hard part or like
there's the liquid part and it's a solid
matter part in a solid matter part is
generally composted and the liquid part
is used as fertilizer any other question
yes
I think they just scooped it up after
afterwards yeah
did I think we usually tied up sometimes
yeah but it's you you know you don't put
their diaper on the counter john-boy
yeah I don't think I've ever seen that
actually but you just collected off the
ground
yeah
yeah so that's a good question uh I
think there are there are other designs
if I guess digesters that don't have all
of these security things necessarily
built into them as well this is a this
is a design that Victor presented I
don't know if you know Victor but he's
one of the D lab instructors and so this
was one of the designs that he presented
and so I don't know the specifics about
the difference different valves but I
can find out for you and get back to you
next week
yeah it just it regulates it makes it so
that if there's too much of a buildup of
gas that the gas can escape somewhere
and it you don't just have pipes like
shooting off because of the high
pressure
that makes sense
so so you have your security valve here
so the Dutch chamber right it's gonna
get bigger okay so you have you have
your bag here then you have your thing
going out to security valve here and
then you have your main valves here and
so when your main valve is off this is
sort of a closed system and so no gas
can escape out of this I'd like because
you have like this is filled up to here
or I'm drawing this wrong but still
normally have like okay so you'll
normally have like your sewage level
something like this and so your gases
can all your gas is contained within
within like this region of your biogas
digester right now and so if this valve
is off and you keep producing more and
more gas your bag isn't get bit getting
bigger and at some point it just gonna
explode because of the excess methane
gas and so what the security valve does
is it'll let out that excess gas to
prevent your system from breaking
generally there's a second switch at the
stove n2 right I'm not sure
yeah I'm not sure about the specific
design
yeah yeah
but the other thing is you also don't
want to have a fully like opens it's
like one full closed system because if
there's like a spark or something like
that the entire thing is just going to
blow up and you
I've I've seen lots of different types
of gas reservoirs
I think the cheapest one you can do is
you can just take another second smaller
bag and seal it and then put an inlet
and outlet on that and then this bag
just fills up and X Y a expanses I get
you
I'm pretty sure is possible to do that
but it's a pretty like sophisticated
process and I've never seen it done on
like in actual like on in rural
developing world only she'd had done or
heard of it being done in like on the
industrial scale
I'm trying to think I mean there's
probably the user and end of it where if
you see the reservoir it's easier to
know how full it is and things like that
it's also a second part that needs to be
protected if you're using a bag to make
it and so if you're leaving it outdoors
like right next to your guess your by I
guess I gesture maybe it's more likely
to get damaged and if you're putting
this inside your house or something like
that or like a more protected area that
would make it easier yeah
if you have a so victor's is actually
like really experience with biogas
digesters so if we have more questions
we can have him come in and talk a
little bit about it we have time and if
you guys are doing a biogas project for
for your specific projects or related to
it then you can also you should also
talk to Victor about it to get more
information and so I'm trying to give
you more of a general idea of how they
work and what things to take into
consideration when building one or
looking at an existing design and I mean
yeah more so than like a very in-depth
thing because there are people in D life
we know a lot more about that yes
digesters than I do so I guess so there
are no other questions before we go down
I'm gonna go through the muddy card
questions from last week's lab most of
the questions were all about the guts of
how a PV panel works in photovoltaics
work yeah we're gonna we're gonna do a
solar cell lab next week and the point
like the first half of that is just
going to be talking to you about how PV
systems work so you guys can wait
another week for that and you'll have it
presented to you and then one person
asked about why shouldn't spot well
galvanized steel and when anything's
galvanized what you're doing is you're
cutting it with zinc so that it doesn't
it doesn't rust and when you try this
weld anything would sink coatings on it
the you vaporize is encoding and it's
pretty toxic to you so if you're doing
you know no really felt well ventilated
area or you doing outdoors it's not a
big deal but if you're doing it indoors
it's toxic so you want to make sure you
avoid welding galvanized materials
so now what we're gonna do is we're
gonna break up into two groups
well first off we're gonna be doing
we're gonna be building five biogas
digesters little modules so you should
group up into groups of three no two or
three until we get five of them yeah so
let's let's break actually let's just do
two let's do four by I guess I gestures
things today so we'll break up into
groups of threes and four and and then
two of those groups are gonna go with
Becca and she's gonna teach you about
plastic sealing and how to make bio gas
slurry from up I guess digester slurry
from manure and water and the other
group is gonna go with me and I'll will
walk you through building the by cutting
the wood and putting it together to
build the biogas digester
you